[Music]
we are at our first week of production
we are in the sound stage and what we
call tent city which is our outpost it's
day one were all really really excited
[Music]
I'm so excited it's just so wonderful to
see everything come together this set is
incredible we're setting for the first
shot of the entire thing
we're really jumping right into it the
10th of a shooting in is my fav a very
hot in here we have lots of little tents
with lots of big cameras and people
nearly missing each other all over the
place we've been getting really
interesting unique shots and still being
able to move really fast which usually
those contradict each other but we're
staying on track which is the goal he
had studs and we had flood and we had
emotional moments and I feel like we
really had all those and at the end it
was just going and going and going and
going ok great we got it going alive a
lot
we're out of the tent though
this is where the Langford live and work
so that's where we pick back up with
Sergei ten years later
camera frame all sound alright sounds
beats
[Music]
you
you